Tuesday morning just had a really
productive meaner sports meeting
off-camera and headed back to New York
City bunch of meetings completely
playoff game with Brandon Steiner
and
[Music]
[Music]
I'm planning I'm grinding that currency
coming up sections of money I'm shining
I'm shining I'm certainly stunning the
buck on me gonna I know they don't know
me but at the my show when they tell me
is nothing so me tomorrow ain't promised
I live my life - window into rubbish
what repercussions of living and
learning working in learning and sharing
my sermon the brothers will pretend but
then don't concern me I'm way to wash up
is immersed to determine what
repercussions of living and learning New
Orleans we may love shipping no barb in
the steady sea but don't do the yard me
wish I could go back with the futures of
perfect
nobody be gathered in that
[Music]
get it right back in it right back was
it enough in this endeavor that might
not work as we women like that we can
look at the ship or anything like that
look at it again nobody make a deal
like that there was a big thank you to
Rick back
be right back once again I'm committed
like that bethought myself a break if we
can connect that we can work at the
shoes or appendage like that
like that yeah I mean as you can imagine
there are so many themes there that are
similar to what's going on in the super
package good space I think when I see
90% decline of growth in the entire
category of fortune 500 CPGs and 2017
but there's some real real missteps on
the way that big brands are spending
media on above the line and specifically
digital like
one of the things that scares me is when
a client comes to me and says great news
were 58 percent digital now when I know
ninety eight ninety percent of that 58
is going to be pushed towards
programmatic banners and pre-rolls
that not a single person on earth is
going to give a crap about boy I really
don't want to do that so let's figure
out how to like minimize that dollar
amount you know yep but I'm going to I'm
I'm on board with you now let them get
it down to like by operating the
business for the rest of the year and
fulfilling our obligations with free
stuff you know what I mean like there's
a way to drive that number down
[Music]
hey guys
[Music]
you can be running it against [ __ ]
fangirls 22:29 because yes I mean I
wasn't so funny I was about to say what
I think I would say to a corporate
client because you're making the
investment I don't seem to see it give
me the dollar exit here the three areas
yeah a hundred percent all right
realize your outlook which is that fast
yeah yep yep yah hey how you been good
legacy that although they're really good
my friend how are you cool good man
life is good good I mean you know you I
just think that you guys can do a lot of
for him and for the brand and I mean
personal I think your global personally
and I think I'm sure you guys think so
too
but listen big biggest could you the
bajillion dollars to win in Africa I
just think you've got a real chance to
do something people so one of the
biggest things with distribution so for
example the mood of the seller your
music on TC nice that's blogs and set
like you take seven vloggers on YouTube
and give them original music assortment
we're making but that legend that we
song we made a popular we started made a
popular if we made a popular people
watch me and I don't we have hundreds of
thousands you get people with millions
you get a family in Ohio that has 11
million people watch them every day
blogging and put your song in there it's
like being on a video game or in a cop
you know in a commercial I mean I think
that I think you should put out music
every day on soundcloud and and and
spotify every day now you know I got you
know I don't know you I don't know your
music process but but there's not a song
you make that shouldn't see the world
you're being too critical of it let the
market decide if you're not going to
make anything disgustingly bad it may
not be a big nor own personal standard
but I know for a fact that you've had
songs that were way bigger than you
thought they were going to be and you've
got songs that you thought were going to
change your career it didn't happen
I do it everyday right I videos and I'm
like this is it hundred million on
Facebook another thing is like what why
is the set a million already got it if
you are gay I love it
let me uh let me do a quick picture with
you in the background give you some love
you said I'll see then we'll talk we'll
talk a lot more data
I definitely like I'd like to make two
videos at 100 115 each like what I'd
like to do here's what I like about it
it probably won't work if it does we're
forever associated with it and it's a
winnable like I don't like saying space
let's go for it it's a trend
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys taking taking some of my own
advice that I've been giving you guys
too
what's not the Apple store hobby oh this
one right here used to be right no it's
okay in the corner okay go
anyway giving you guys some of my taking
some of my own advice just came out of a
meeting with a guy who I'm not doing
business with actively but I have in the
past who's just ridiculously smart and
punch I'm being I need to be spending
time with people that I see myself
spending time with thirty years from now
and so I'm starting to allocate more and
more time on that I also right before
that met with a former employee once in
Lane are always in Vayner where
employees if you see this hit me up so
I'm just trucking along my day but big
punch line is need to continue to hack
you know I kind of talk about like at a
winning friend kind of losing friend
it also comes to your calendar trying to
add one more meeting with somebody that
you think you're going to be in
friendship or in business with in 30
years especially because of both it's
just smart and so I'm trying to scribble
down and go a little bit deeper on some
of these seven to ten winners and one to
three super winners and so really focus
more than ever on that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]